Okay.
Good evening.
If you have not figured it out yet. I'm not Phil Sally.
I am filling in for Phil. So.
Three of you heard that really it
is something you may know already, but
Carol feels wife Carol her
father died yesterday.
And so they went to Broken Arrow to be with the family and so
we'll pray for them tonight and
Yeah as they process through that.
Handle that with the family extended. I think all the kids got to go
up there and see him before he passed but still.
You could be praying for them.
The men's tailgates tomorrow night and everything. He's up
there and Broken Arrow. So we're we're taking over that as well tomorrow,
but then here tonight. He asked
me to fill in and so I get to do this with you tonight and
kind of talk through.
Chapter 9 reviewing week eight and looking into chapter
9 and so let me pray for us as we get started tonight.
Lord thank you for the time we get to spend talking about
disciple making thank you for the people who have committed
over the last couple months to just invest.
Pour into each other learn grow
develop into this.
This command you've given us from Matthew 28 To
Go Make Disciples.
Baptizing and teaching to obey May that become normal
for us that become who we are as individuals and
who we are as a church. That's what you've given us as that directional vision
and we want to be that
So may this group catalyze many groups
towards that end.
I pray for the silly family tonight, especially.
As you comfort them with the comfort that your spirit
gives.
I pray for Carol as she's now lost both parents.
I pray that you'd give her peace and the grandkids and
great grandkids that they would all see.
That this really as they've said is
a good thing as they've seen him.
Decline quickly.
And now he's home and so we're grateful for that truth and
the hope they have in you.
Grief, yes, but we grieve
with hope so give them peace this weekend
words to say counsel to give to those who
hurt.
Thank you. God help us tonight to see what you
have for us in Jesus name. Amen.
I do not have his iPad and so
we're just going to go old school. Okay, you're gonna
follow along. You've got the papers right in front of you if you
don't have those yet table at the back Jill can help you with that?
but we're gonna review quickly through the kind of main themes of
this whole 12-week section of
our lives and really
As we build into each week these truths that
the discipling pathway is how we move people from the
big gathering on a Sunday into a smaller
group called Community groups that
place where we have a lot of things that happen for our benefit
and growth and Community relationships. But
ultimately Down Deeper that that's not
the end game is just to be in a community group. It's to be trained and
and developed equipped how to
love Jesus and live scent and then eventually to a disciple making group
like this. We call Micro groups or D groups three four
five people together as we've been talking about in this room.
Now a disciple we talk about making disciples and one
who's committed to following Jesus being changed by Jesus
and his mission is their focus. That's what we would Define
a disciple to be in a really small form.
And so when we talk about making disciples that means we need to
be shooting for that in our lives and others
lives having an intentional leader in this group relational environment
reproducible process that this can can multiply as
we've talked about becoming a hub for disciple
making here. That's what we want to see. This is how we
get there in many ways. Holy spirit's a
teacher the Bible's curriculum. The end product is transformation. You don't
have to have a degree you don't have to have all the training and
history in the church anything like that. If you have God's
word, you have the Holy Spirit in you and through you
and we look forward to transformation. That's really all
it is. And so we engage explorers. We connect Believers grow
disciples and go multiply.
That's the kind of pathway process. We're looking at
here.
so we're way down into this now looking at practical steps
from Etheridge and Ogden last week
the very similar recommendations if you remember that from last
time just
Overview quickly through those things really about
praying first like how you start a group is basically what
we're talking about.
Ogden first says to pray invite people
kind of cast The Vision tell them what is involved in
this have that conversation about what this looks like
expect certain things and then set this
meeting and get going. That's just what we want to do is
just get started.
It won't look the same a year 10 years from now than it does
right now just realize that it will grow and it
will change you will change your group will change you just gotta
get started. My tendency is to want to have it all figured out
before we get started. Like that's just not going to work with this you
can have principles and some some main themes,
but you just got to get going and watch the Lord work through
and in you
So now we move into chapter 9 how to make disciples how to launch
really this launching of a micro group. We talked about
the the planning of it last week with Ethridge and Ogden.
Now, how do we actually launch it?
Now here's a question that is often brought up. This one-on-one versus
micro group one-on-one versus three to five
and that's a common conversation among disciple makers
people ask me all the time. As I was doing my doctoral work on
this. It was a Common Thread that like, okay. Well, I got
discipled one-on-one. This really worked for me. Of course. I got
discipled in a group with three and it really worked for me of course, right? So
there's not a right or wrong way to this.
And so we want to make sure that we don't exclude anyone for doing
one-on-one. It's not wrong both can
get to life transformation. We're investing in life.
But what we would say is that here's why
we would say three four, maybe five people are better
in this not right or wrong, but
just a little bit better because of these things if you're
a one-on-one setting if you miss a week, so to speak you're
you're two weeks out from a meeting now, ideally your
conversations happen throughout the week. So that's not just
the one time you talk.
But it just means you're you're not going to be able to sit down
for an hour together if you're one of you is out for whatever
reason.
So groups of three to four you have some some continuity that
you're going to be meeting every week pretty much if even if
one person misses, they're still consistency there. We
also see scriptures clear that this happens in groups a lot.
Now we see one-on-one in scripture. We also see groups a
whole lot in scripture. It's in the nature of God. It's
in the call to be in relationships between husband and wife in
Genesis 2. It's the family structure as we go forward.
That's God creating us to be in community
with people again one-on-one. Yes, but all
so for the most part in larger groups
than that all through the Old Testament, you see
these things show up of community examples the New
Testament shows examples of community even Jesus we've talked
about this a lot. He had crowds following him. He pulled
out 72 to make these these
missional efforts into these cities and he'd send
them out two by two, but he pulled this 72 out of
the crowd then he pulled even 12 from there.
But then the three Peter James and John he pulled
even further out from them. He wanted to invest deeper
into these few that ended up being the leaders of the new church.
So he took people with him he was in community with people. That's
what God does to transform tribes and
communities and peoples and cultures.
We structured around these ideas of smaller groups.
Why is that important King Solomon? This is
Page Six you go into if Ecclesiastes 4:9.
King Solomon understood this the wisest man who ever lived he wrote
this down.
I think we should listen to that and so he says two are
better than one life is better when we live together.
Two are better than one because they have a good reward for their toil if
they fall one will lift up his fellow if but woe
to him who is alone when he falls has none other to lift him
up.
Again, if two lie together to keep warm, but how can one keep warm alone?
Though a man might Prevail against one two will
withstand him a threefold chord is not quickly broken.
Just all throughout that that's a very familiar passage to
us who've been in church any length of time. We see two or better
than one. There's a good reward for that you start to learn from each
other differently than you would by yourself. You hear different insights two
or better than one in that sense.
We learn better together if they fall you'll be lifted up
that's talking about Shepherds right where they
would be kind of walking together in sort of close-knit groups.
And so the shepherd has
to go find a sheep that's down in the Ravine and he goes and gets
it and he can't get back up.
Shepherd puts his crook down there helps him up and all these things or
he falls down or hurts himself. They have brothers around
them.
So that's the idea even spiritually we're talking about is that you
need people around you.
And that's not easily found in a large
group setting on a Sunday morning.
You can't have people that you can really lean on because you don't
even know most of those people at times you might know names and
faces, but you don't know their lives and they can't know you and you
don't trust deeply towards that end. So this
idea of two are better than one helps us learn and grow
and experience Community together to lie together
to keep warm, right? That's the idea. They're out in
the freezing desert by themselves. They
have a blanket. That's it. If you're together two or
three you can huddle together and keep warm from each other. That's the
idea of that.
So you find warmth in life in community, we're stronger together. That's the
two that can withstand one. That's the
three-fold Strand the threefold chord that's all showing
that we are stronger together.
So these ideas show us that it's yeah again,
we could debate the one versus the three or four
but still the point is you need someone we need someone around
us. We need people around us to be
stronger together think of the Roman soldiers when they'd
go into battle. They would have their Shields almost locked together
in the front even over the top. Sometimes they
would create this wall. So arrows are shooting
at them or or flaming bombs would
come at them and they would just huddle behind this and they would stand together
in this one by himself with dangerous,
but all the shields surrounding each other.
That's what we're talking about here.
Now we we talk about these groups in three to four maybe five
in a group those need to be I
would believe both men together or
women together.
And the reality is that you have Community groups many of us have Community groups that
are mixed men and women together some of your larger Community
groups that are just women or just men that's fine.
But the idea is that when you have mixed company men and women together, there's things that
you would not say.
That you might say in a group of three guys together.
Just that it's not I'm not saying something that's silly
or something. That's a poor joke a course joking I'm
saying things about your soul things about your struggling with you
wouldn't share in a large group where where there's
men and women together things that you don't really I don't
know those people very well.
And that's that's something that I don't feel comfortable talking
about in front of a man and those kind of things you get a group
of three or four women together or three or four men together and and
that's a lot more open a lot more willing. There's
trust and there's this there's this understanding that
we're all in this together.
And so I would say that's the best way to do this. I think there's
a risk involved if you start to mix that together in groups
of three or four.
Now what do we do now? I'm not going to go through this. This is pages eight through
the end. It really has a lot of detailed
instructions as you begin to think about planning
out your micro group your D group as you
go from this place in the next couple weeks as we launch you
out around Thanksgiving and say Here's what we're going to
do. We're gonna challenge you to start groups as Phil has
said repeatedly like the goal of this is not for us just to
be in here and to enjoy this study together. The goal is
to be a disciple maker because God's called you to and
equipped you to do that.
So how do you do that? These are some steps you go from the
middle of page eight.
in this section intentional leaders model
expectations
You need to be doing this first.
I'm talking to a men's Retreat Friday and
Saturday and I'm talking to men about what it looks about a minute
Church minute home minute work and one of
the things about being a man at home is like you better
be set in the pace in this thing including and
repentance when you blow it. If you want your kid to learn
how to repent you better know how to repent and lead them towards that so it's
the idea same thing here. If you're gonna be a leader of a group you got
a model what it looks like to be a part of this group.
And then you think of what the the curriculum you're
going to use if there's going to be any curriculum. I mean, obviously the Bible
itself can be your curriculum. But if if there's something else you
want to add in maybe a new believer needs something along
the way we got to think through what you're going to do with
that questions. You're gonna ask model expectations for
transparency as well.
That you're going to set the pace for how open your
group is.
Are you going to share some of the things that you struggle with? If you
don't they're not you need to open that up in
your own life because they need to relate to you.
So you kind of think through the planning of it. There are a lot of detailed instructions there
then the middle of 10 you get to the first few meetings. Okay. So now
we want to start this. What do we do?
How do we actually go about doing this? Well, you kind
of think through that Covenant idea. What are the expectations you get to know
each other which you have done in this room right getting to
know stories getting to know our hearts and who we are those things
are important share your faith Journey.
One of the things that I've had consistently told to
me throughout this process, I haven't seen it yet. But as I've
talked to plenty of disciple makers they've seen this happen where
you have somebody say in a community group
that's 30 people and you start to see like there's a couple
of us that we need to really pull out and get together in this way. And you start
talking about these things you start to expect certain things start
to ask questions about things.
Say tell us your faith Journey.
Tell us how you came to Christ. They can't tell you.
And through the course of the disciple making
group you make a disciple like somebody who's
not.
Comes to Faith in the middle of this becomes a disciple
of Christ through this process that they
thought they were believer, but then they could never share and they'd never had
anybody sit and challenge them on it and I don't mean confront them about it,
but just ask them.
If sat in church, they sat in a Sunday school class their entire life
never been asked that question.
But in a group of three people you're having a conversation about this and they
they stumble they don't know what belief is and
what faith is.
And you share the gospel and you lead them to Christ and then you're starting there.
I haven't seen it in my life in that context, but
I've heard it over and over that that happens.
Just by asking a faith Journey question.
And so you kind of lead that first stretch of time as as
an intentional leader, but then the
goal would always be to shift leadership away.
Like with my guys that I'm eating with tomorrow morning. My constant goal
is to say you guys can do this. It's not about me leading you this
is us leading each other you can do this. You can do this. So
where they feel like
At some point they can pick up and move on to lead
a number of guys themselves.
And then help equip them to lead and equip them to
lead. That's the point is yes. It takes initiation.
But then it doesn't mean you take it and run with it yourself forever.
You let people lead and you give them in responsibilities and
you help them understand they can do this, too.
Because if Jesus gave us this command to make disciples and that's
all of us.
Then we better all be able to know how to do it.
And I'll be equipped how to do it. So this is part of the process as a
leader you help them see how to do it.
Okay, so that's a quick blast through
you got some questions there that you can talk through about
this about when you're thinking ahead of how to plan and how to
get started with this. You got the micros group
discussion questions there and so just take that time as
we get into it. Normally we leave you
about an hour and so want to be faithful to that time if
you are here and this is your first time I don't
know if you've been here or not. So if this is literally your first time on
a Wednesday night where you're seeing things like this and hearing things like
that come up here and talk to me Jill will be
up here too. We can connect you to a group because that's the point of this is not just to listen
to lectures is to get into a group practice this so,
you know what to do when we go forward. So if it's your first
time come find us down here as soon as we do this break up
time here, and then we'll get you connected to a group, but I'm
so excited really again. I just wanted before we
break up. I
I've been dreaming about things like this for
seven years.
In a church. I started my doctoral work about
seven years ago now and this was
it relational disciple making in a church setting.
so I had studied and studied enough wanted to
see it happen and I've tried to start it kind of organically myself and
then
then God just plops in her lap. Here we go. And so
I'm so excited to see each one of you involved in this
wanting to do this.
You all going to feel over your head in this it's the
reality.
But the beautiful part of it is that you've got the holy spirit inside of
you as a believer.
And he says he's going to empower you
to do what your commanded to do. This is
not too hard for you scripture says
you can do it. And so I'm excited to see us do it.